الى مصر حيث انتشلت السلطات المصريه
المركب الذي احترق قباله ساحل البحر
الاحمر بعدما قالت ان ثلاثه مواطنين
بريطانيين فقدوا بعدما اشتعلت النيران في
قارب غطس كانوا على متنه قباله الساحل على
البحر الاحمر كما قالت محافظه البحر
الاحمر ان اكثر من عشره من افراد الطاقم
طاقم واثنا عشر سائحا بريطانيا تم انقاذهم
عندما اشتعلت النيران في المركب قباله
مدينه مدينه هناك
تنضم الينا من الغردقه ندى حجازي مراسله
العربيه ندى يعني مل جديد بهذا الملف
خصوصا بان موضوع يعني اشتعال القارب اثار
الزار لدى السياح هناك
التحقيقات الى ماذا وصلت وكل التفاصيل معك
تفضل
اهلا بك المركبه الان بصدد اخماد النيران
وتبريدها لفحص السبب الرئيسي او الحقيقي
اللي اشتعالها ولكن وفق المؤشرات المبدئيه
اشتعال كان بسبب ماسك كهربائي في غرفه
المحركات
والان يتم فحصها مره اخرى
وفحص المركب وتفقد اذا كانت جسامين
التلات سائحين المفقودين بداخلها واذا لم
يجدوها بداخل المركب فستتوجه الفرق
والتواقم المختصه الى اعماق البحر لتفقدها
يعني لان وقتها سيكون من المؤكد انهم قد
غرقوا في الاعماق اما عن تفاصيل تفاصيل
المركب
واشتعالها والرحله نفسها فالرحله كانت
المفروض من يوم سته ليوم 11 كانت المفروض
متوجهه من المارينا الجديده
بمرسى علم الى مارينا بورت غارب رحله
سياحيه
المركب على متنه 15 سائح بريطاني 10 10
اشخاص طاقم المركب واثنين مرشدين سياحيين
تم انقاذ الجميع فقط ثلاثه مفقودين والذي
تم انقاذهم هم بحاله جيده الان موجودين
بمركز سياحي قريب من نقطه انقاذهم
وهي يعني الموضوع كله اخذ اخذ بعض الوقت
لان كمان المركب همم الرياح والامواج
دفعتها بعيدا عن مكان الحادث تقريبا 20
كلم داخل
انتشالها ياخذ وقتا من يتولى الرقابه على
يعني جهوزيه هذه القوارب لكي تكون مؤهله
لنقل سواح ومن يدقق اذا ما كانت معايير
السلامه فعلا متابعه داخل هذه القوارب
بالطبع جميع المراكب الموجوده في في
البحار يتم فحصها بشكل دوري وقبل ان تاخذ
التصاريح
يعني
لتبدا رحلاتها يجب فحصها جيدا ويجب ان تمر
على اكثر من جهه ولكن موضوع الماسه
الكهربائي هي هو حادث فردي يعني
لا يعيب المركب او
وليس وليس شيئا
يعني
ملك معرضه لهذا النوع من الحوادث
شكرا لك ندى حجازي مراسله العربيه حدثتنا
من الغردقه لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات